(classical music)
(motor running)
(traffic noise)
(classical music)
- [Mark] Hi, Rebecca.
- [Rebecca] Hi Mark (laughs).
- [Mark] How are you this morning?
- Ah, bored, just genuinely bored.
- What's going on?
- Nothing, I been on for hours.
I, I found this one outfit.
I was at work and this guy tried
to caress my ass last night,
it was kinda hot all night
and two days ago I saw Mary Kate Wilson.
I'm living a hellhole of youth, Mark.
Nothing's happening.
This pandemic it's running
its fucking course.
Why is everything so boring?
Everything other countries open wide.
- You're in a very
different mood this morning.
You're all wind up.
- I just, I feel like a teenager today.
- What vitamins did you take last night?
- I took some Klonopin
and some bonded pant
L vitamin C.
Let's call it Molly.
I took some molly.
We added a line of Molly MDM
because there's nothing else
to do in life.
Mark. The clubs are all closed.
The kids are all dead
and Hollywood is better off than Madden.
How are you doing Mark?
- I'm all right
- Good to hear, can I
take a sip of my water?
- Go ahead.
- Thank you
- I like what you're wearing today.
- Do you think?
I feel a little basic
but the best out of all my
outfits, it's the most me?
- What is that?
- It's a little products
like a little shift dress.
It's kind of silky, I picked
it up from the trashcan.
And this, I picked up
on a sleeping person
and his leather jacket.
I had to grab from someone's pile
and run about a mile and a half.
I figured were talking to him.
I grabbed it from the car.
- How much of your daily existence is?
(inaudible)
- Robbery?
- Robbery is the entirety of my game.
Due to my lifestyle as a pariah,
people don't give me money
because of the fact that I wear skirts.
And I'm very flattened
and say, God bless you.
Can I have a dollar for some soda?
As opposed to just ask for
someone to buy you food.
They always do that.
Like, I'm going to buy you a meal.
I don't want 20 dollars of fucking
tacos from a taco stand.
I'd rather a 30 dollar smoked salmon pizza
from Spago's, but your broke.
So most of it is literally larceny.
I'm committing pure larceny.
I steal my clothes.
I steal my food and I steal my water.
I see things in bump-outs.
I just grab them.
This is how I survive Mark.
- What do you worry about?
You worry about anything.
- Nothing. I worry
about like getting bored
or going to sleep mainly.
Going to sleep to me
is honestly, it's like
after five days or five hours
my body is so tired from,
cause I walk I'm a normal
- So you'll stay up for days.
- Why not?
- And then when you do sleep,
you sleep for how long?
- Maybe a few days to a few hours.
I do a long sleep.
I a sleep I passed
out. I don't sleep til I pass out
- So what's the longest
you've slept straight?
- 14 Hours. But like,
you know what I mean?
But 14 hours is the
longest I've ever slept.
Mostly it's like a seven
to nine hours sleep.
I sleep a lot because
I have nothing to do.
I'm lucky I have no job or nothing.
Keeping me no wife or kids or any of that.
Yeah. Dude on the side,
I haven't had sex in
fucking months but that's not important.
I'm sorry.
- When you do have sex,
who do you have sex with?
- Men, sometimes women. I'm a little kinky
but also a little romantic,
but mostly it's people
actually do not know how to have sex.
I don't get your ugly cup,
like showing me your junk
and asking me to put it in my mouth.
This weird fellatio obsession,
that poor men have,
men of a certain social class,
have an obsession with fellatio.
Fellatio takes about 10 to 20 minutes,
to produce anything.
Fucking three minutes.
You know what I mean?
Like just rough fuck me.
Its not like rape me,
but rough fuck me. But
women there's just hours
of making out and shit
because I'm barely a lesbian
and I'm like a lipstick lesbian.
- What do you describe yourself as?
Are you a cross-dresser
or are you a transgender?
- I consider myself a woman,
but unfortunately due
to my- the fact that I'm
I'm homeless and have no resources.
I can't afford the scissors
to drop my Dick off.
And I can't even afford 2 dollars
for a fucking visa Mark.
I'm not gonna stuff my tits,
because I'm not lying to anyone.
You know?
So I'd rather consider myself a woman.
But for now just call me a tranny.
I'm not a drag queen because
they work for what they do.
They're different than call me a tranny,
considering my social ...
- I called you a cross
dresser in the last video.
- Yeah, you called me a cross dresser
and people commented in the video
but you're right, because I looked like a
cross dresser.
- Yeah you have a full beard.
- I still have a full beard.
- So he's going to be transgender
because I have a beard
because Mark, I can't
afford these reasons.
And honestly shaving
takes about ten minutes.
There's nothing I'm going to do
more than two minutes.
- I could've put a flannel shirt on you,
you would have been a lumber jack
- I would've been a lumberjack.
I'm going to boy.
I would've been well, not Kurt Cobain
but maybe I would have been
like, I know Lucas Ball.
I don't know.
How have you been?
What have you been up to Mark?
How's Mississippi?
- I've been doing the same thing,
I do all the time down here.
- Nice that you work.
I wish I had a job.
It's just, I don't do manual labor.
- So I mean, where do you see
your life going from here?
You've been down here for,
you've been on the street for how long?
- Oh my god, Who's hiring?
I just don't have an ID.
- That, you would get a job.
You think you'd be able to hold a job?
- If I can get a job, I'll hold a job.
I don't know how to get a job.
Mark I don't actually
know how to pay bills.
I'm coming from the streets.
I don't know how to do this shit.
- Oh, how old you ?
- I'm 23.
- You're 23.
- Yeah, I'm 23.
I was born August 4th, 1997.
Yeah. Sometimes since I was
about 15 as the only time
it was just so hard to get shit done.
I mean, this is just system.
It's like living in the suburbs.
Do you have an apartment out here?
I started all this.
The amount of paperwork and work.
Didn't meet the criteria.
- If you could do anything
it'd be a fashion designer or something.
- No I'd be, I'd be in a magazine editor.
That would be my ideal job.
That's classic intern,
Ill fetch coffee for crew.
I think they have the, the Vogue building.
The Connie NAF building.
It's in the worst area I ever.
I was a story there.
I was once sleeping out there
and about seven hours into my sleep.
Bouncer comes up to me
and just wake me up.
I'm like bitch I'm in fashion.
What are you doing to me? He's like
why are you're sitting run
over really to get away.
And I come to the punch him,
and I just miss like a grazed his chest.
I have a good punch.
I have a mean punch.
I'm a five in Brewster brothers.
It's like get away from here
you're annoying, where I'm sleeping.
So I want to go into the one Lisa Love.
She works at Vogue.
She does.
She's a West coast editor.
I have to work there because
like working with celebrities
I wish that calling us to
move their offices here
because it doesn't make
sense its in New York
but it's an economic capital.
- Some of the opportunity
like that came up
would you clean up and get your...
- Ill do everything, Ill sell the soul.
Ill do everything I literally sit there
and pluck his beard hair.
If I can just literally fetch coffee
for them for about 10 dollars a day.
If I, this is the level
of where I'm at in life
Mark. I've no accessibility to anything.
I'm a real social pry here.
I'm a hermit or some shit in West side.
He treats me this way.
It's not my fault.
People that are really rude and cruel
to me considering this the way they are.
People always say, they call me a fag,
call me a tranny to
suddenly go away, go away.
I'm like, why is that?
Like so fucking homophobic.
They just say, I'm a faggot.
I'm a gay guy.
What's wrong with a gay guy,
and what's really annoying
because you can't get
drugs in West Hollywood.
It's one strip with 10 clubs.
And it's like all these big houses.
So it's easy for me to make money there,
but I can't get drugs.
So what am I going to party without drugs?
I'll just go down to the clubs
And they always let me, the best music.
I like, sir.
They do some show shit.
I like West Hollywood.
I remember watching that utopia
of a strip mall of clubs is LA,
I'm embarrassed.
I went to the Viper room
Mark, but you know what?
They wouldn't let me
into the Chateau Marmot.
These are trying to get
them you're at night
because they would not, like I said,
I met Lindsay Lohan there once,
she was sweet, but a little stale.
- Hmm. You're hanging out
in the right neighborhoods
- I'm trying.
- To make something happen ..
- It was honestly the best
place in life at the end
of the day, Mark.
Why? Because in the
business you gotta be in the
business to be in business.
You need to have ID.
Some sort of
- Anything goes here right?
- Anything goes here.
Sure. Let's call it.
That it's accessible to me.
And for my clothes, I, from my water
I can put my food, everything else.
It's like walking through a waste line
- But if you were walking
around West Hollywood all day, all night,
- The worst is Beverly Hills.
- Oh yeah.
- It's about a three-hour
walk to get anywhere
because all houses, I wouldn't,
I've been looking at houses.
Like I love that.
- What's The worst thing
that's happened to you?
But down the street.
- Getting maybe raped
and shot even physically.
I mean, honestly, it's
like someone comes on
punches me or just as much or something.
Crazy thing some guy
hit me with an umbrella.
The worst thing that ever happened
to me was eight months ago, I was hit
in the head with a metal
pipe because I tried to
steal someone's clothes,
someone buy their clothes,
and they found me and I
walked down Venice beach
for an hour bleeding out of my head.
No one done anything.
But I was like, I couldn't feel a thing.
I was so high. Bleeding
out my fucking head
No one did a thing.
Good for them.
Bougie bitches.
Eventually I was just
like the whole time trying to find a dress
because we didn't have thing.
You're like
I survive off clothes Mark.
My triangle consist my
clothes, drugs, food
water, everything else.
So I'm very lucky that
I'm so self-sufficient I
used to be such a party
girl, but we're here.
So like you couldn't
tell us to like be next
or wherever and so conservative here
but just come dive into Southern bang.
I don't know.
I miss Paris Hilton in that lecture.
Demi Moore, Melanie Griffith.
It's okay.
It'll it'll bounce back.
The official count was a
new movie called Mankin.
So shitty
It goes to the French movie.
Maybe the french movies
gone girl. It's not one
of my favorite ones
because I'm very artsy.
Wasn't ever a Hollywood movie.
- It's gone girl. It's
the most beautifully
- Rebecca, can I buy you some food?
So maybe we can get some...
- Please buy me some food
- ...food in your system.
- Its not a date honey, just talk to me.
I'm so lonely, but it's kind of a day.
Thanks for being so sweet to me Mark.
You are the most subsidies
that I have received are you're
on the street because people are poor.
People are poor.
I'll give you broke bitches.
Every people don't give Wilmington.
Because you don't do
that, when I have money
why would I go up to a
person and give them money
that's so weird. Your
laying down on the floor
why would they ...
- Maybe ff you get some food,
you'll come down a little bit.
- Maybe...
You're gonna be the one
Mark, I'm doing this
because this is the most
anything I've had in days.
(sings)
(inaudible)
I love your posts.
Kind of like you remind
me of Brooke Shields
like Calvin Klein hot.
Fine.
- All right,
Rebecca.
- All right, Mark.
- Thank you for visiting me again.
- Thank you, Mark.
Is that it?
Oh, well that was easy today.
It's short but sweet.
- Hi
- Rebecca.
- Mark
- Welcome back
- Why thank you.
- How are things today?
Is it yesterday you were here?
- Terrible. I think it
was like three days ago.
Three or four days ago?
Yeah. Terrible, terrible.
- What happened?
- Awful. I was attack last
night by a man sexually.
Oh, this went through skid row
was like four in the morning.
And this guy came at me and
he was on a bike and he like
he comes up and grabs my ass,
and I aint know what to do, so I was like
smacks his arm.I was like
get the fuck away from me
And, and it was like in
one of the alley airways
like maybe like maybe like
a mile or two from here.
And he's disgusting.
The most disgusting fucking man ever.
I was like 45 years old or something shit
black, fat guy.
He was like, like a fat
DJ Mustard or something.
And-and he's like, boo what
the fucks wrong with you
come on baby. Come on baby.
I'm like, I'm not your fucking baby.
He's like, bitch you're a dude.
I'm like, well, thank you
sir but I am maybe a woman
to someone and you
know, all that chit chat
shit I do.
So while I was sitting talking my shit
he grabs a fucking knife
he's like get on the
fucking ground. I'm like,
no, pulls out his dick.
He says, get on the fucking ground.
Cause I'm like, no.
So then he's got the fucking knife on me.
I'm about to get to stabbed.
And he's like, suck my fucking dick.
I'm like, no.
So he literally shoved me on the ground.
Like shows us the bike down
shoves me down on the ground,
fucking bends me over.
And then I'm like, what?
And then he says
on top of me, but like,
like concentration camps
like track star and then
like, Oh then five minutes
we just sitting there going
like waiting and waiting.
- This is out in the open?
- Yes, but like not too open.
It's like, you know the side streets here.
It's like such street
where the warehouses are.
- Yeah, no traffic.
- No traffic like people don't stop.
Like, I'm screaming like a bitch.
You know what I mean?
But once it's inside,
you're like, it's over.
It's over, you know?
Yeah.
- It must be horrible to deal with them.
- I don't, I don't care.
It was just so in the way.
And he stole, he stole everything I had
I had some really pretty shit
and I'm, I'm more lost on the
on the goods, stole my
purse, lucky I found this
I found this next to a trash can
and there was mud on the floor.
So I have mud on me
now I smell disgusting.
I want to shower.
I don't want to hug right
now. Or anybody to touch me.
but like, it's just it's the process.
It's not even the thing.
You know what I mean?
I'm fighting with trauma.
I'm not traumatized.
It's just, there's so
many mechanics involved
- But I think he must
be traumatized at some
- Do I have to be, don't
have to, it gets annoying.
- Well, I think you just
you always discount the effect
that the street life has
on you.
And I wonder if you don't
get tired of this lifestyle.
- Of course I do.
But it's, it's there.
It's convenient, but
what am I going to say?
Ooh, I want, whereas my
Knight in shining armor
whereas my EBT card, I don't know.
Of course I'm tired of
this at the same time.
I love it too much.
I'm sick of the elements of it.
That hurt.
You know what I mean?
Like if I would complain, I complain
like I'm sick of having to be harassed.
I'm sick of having to
wait to like the process
of begging people for money.
I'm sick of having to
be made to be a pariah.
I'm sick of being, having to be a victim.
I don't want to be a victim
but I have to be, is it my fault?
Sure. I'm the one who's out here.
You know what I mean?
Like, I'll go to the SRO.
Do you know how many
months it takes for the SRO
to get you place?
I go to the EBT office, you
know how many weeks it takes
to fucking, you know what ?
And then why?
And then what, you know, it was just, yeah
- This is a good sign that you're
getting tired of this life.
- Is it?
I wouldn't say so.
- I think it is.
- I want it to be, but, and then what, Oh
I'm going to put in the work to get a job.
I really would, Mark.
It was just, there's a, there's
a lot of issues involved.
It's mainly identification
and through the hard
for me to get an ID, because
it's impossible to get an ID.
So I'm out here.
I don't know where they don't
do fingerprints counters
so I didn't have to go all
the way back to New York.
Just to get identification.
That's literally it by
the way, pretty much.
But you know, if I would say
that the one thing that like that's
in the way that's about it.
- So Rebecca, you were
telling me just a second ago
about your childhood.
- Yes. So I was born in
Paris and I live in Paris
til I was about three and my
dad worked for the UNESCO.
So he got an assignment to
go work in the Cairo in Egypt
like doing like excavation
for the Egyptian government.
So like I grew up really rich
really fucking rich, oil money.
I don't want to say my last name.
And so we went, we used
to live in a mansion.
A, huge mansion in Egypt
and like the suburbs.
And I lived there til I was about 14.
When I was 14 I got kicked out of school.
And my parents sent me to a
boarding school in England.
It was called Rochester
Independent College.
And I used to be like a real heavy druggy
as do a lot of coke when I was a teenager.
Like I've been to rehab like four times
swear on my soul, swear
on my fathers, the truth.
And so my parents sent me
to rehab and then I got like
get kicked in and out of
here, I'm in another rehab
like gloss scholars type shit.
So they sent me to a boarding school
in England for a year and
I wouldn't stop drinking.
So the day of my exams,
my they're called GCFS.
I fell asleep.
I wouldn't study.
I used to go to sleep my exams.
So I got kicked out
and then they sent me
again to rehab for a bit.
And then I lived at home
from like 15 to about 17.
And then when I was 18
my dad had moved to America
cause he had some business here.
So I went to go live with him right.
- Where was this?
- In Boston. Boston, Massachusetts.
And then he got me an
apartment in Brookline
at 34 Thatcher Street,
literally 34 Thatcher Street.
Sub-level unit was
really shitty, like cheap
like real it's apartments.
And my dad's like, you know
like distant fathers when you're treated
like your father's never there.
Like Mr. X and the Nanny Diaries.
So he was never home.
You know what I mean?
So he just got me an apartment
and ditched me.
and then he moved to like
I cant remember he said
he somewhere in Dubai
or something you know what I mean?
He had business as a business man
and then ditch me in America.
So I got bored and I was like
I want to go on the road and be a hippie.
You know what I mean?
With these bum kids, I was
like, I want to be a hippie.
So I went to New York for
like a month and I did that.
And it was weird for me
because New York is the type
of city where you do that.
You know, it was just the closest one.
It was like, like a four hour bus ride.
And I'll never forget.
I bought three suitcases worth of clothes.
And I had a camera.
I used to do photo shoots, like on my own.
I'll show you my Instagram, didn't I show
my Instagram, I show you my Instagram.
Yeah. I did an Instagram as
do fashion shoots on my own.
I got no likes.
And I went there with three suitcases
my camera up my first day there.
I got mugged.
Guy, stole my camera and my wallet
and my ID and one of my bags of clothes.
So I'm walking around
in New York for hours
with two bags of clothes.
I don't know what to do with my life.
So this woman bought me a meal.
I was like, Hmm.
Are you telling me, you just sit there?
You look sad people to give you money.
It's like, Hmm.
So I tried it out.
I got a a hundred dollars.
I was like, Ooh, spent it all on drugs.
(laughs)
And then I also lost the other suitcases.
So I was down to only
one suitcase of clothes
mostly dresses, gowns
suffers, go thrift shopping.
And then I spent about a month living
on those clothes and doing
that about a month in.
And I was like, I don't want
to be a homeless person.
I'm sick of asking people for money,
it was like, fine. I'll go back to Boston.
I went back to Boston, but
I didn't have my credit card
and I couldn't afford a phone.
So I could call my dad to
get the fucking ID back.
I lost his number and he doesn't have
a Facebook or an email or anything.
He's so old school.
So my electricity got cut off,
my gas got cut off,
everything gets cut off.
My lights, my water,
my toilet was clogged.
I don't know how to do
any of these things.
I don't even know how to wipe a floor.
So imagine like living
in a fucking shit stain
and there's like pots and pans everywhere.
Fucking shit everywhere.
I'm like, so I left, I
I just walked out of my
life and walked into this.
I went back to New York.
So then after that, I went
to New York and I met these voodoo people.
I lived with them for a bit.
We used to practice in the street.
They're all homeless.
And they're all these homeless witches.
And they're just practicing.
And that's where I learned.
It was the girl Skylar on the street.
And she took me under her wing
and she did everything for me,
everyday she come give me makeup.
She had cigarettes and drugs
and I'll, I reversed it.
I'll never forget this.
Just trying to came up to me.
And she was like, the first
time anybody did anything nice
to me, it's like, are you hungry?
She worked at McDonald's.
And like, it's my birthday.
So she took me to Stonewall the club and
and she did a collection for me, 40 bucks.
And they played Rihanna for me.
It was the best night of my life.
Mark I never felt,
being homeless is the first time
I ever felt anyone cared about me.
You know what I mean?
It was the first time I
never had friends growing up.
- What about your parents?
Your family?
- Dude they suck?
You're like really reserved,
really strict, really strict.
And my mother was very physically abusive
very physically abusive.
She'll pull me by my hair,
like I'll be bleeding.
And you couldn't tell
anyone I'm not going to go
to school and be like
- You have any siblings?
- One younger brother.
I've been in therapy like my whole life.
I grew up like Edie Sedgwick.
You know Edie Sedgwick?
Edie Sedgwick, I'm the Edie Sedgwick of
homelessness. True fucking story.
(sighs) Good for me
- So that's your life story?
Well, yes, but with a dick on top
(laughs)
- And then you came to LA.
- And then I came No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
First I went to New Orleans,
Virginia,
Miami.
LA sucks,
Virginia raves,
New Orleans. Oh my God.
So much food, so many parties.
So many things happened.
You don't pay for anything.
And in New Orleans you
have like all these witches
they live in squats.
They give you 50 bucks a month
and you're living with
all these bum witches
Miami started as follows the
first day there I meet a woman.
She goes here yet.
My she's a goddess.
She was me, a phone, five
oranges and a pack of cigarettes.
A week later, I wake up on the beach.
A man wakes me up with a line of Coke,
from french toast sticks on his penis.
And then I broke into um,
(laughs)
- Rebecca. You're not
wearing any underwear.
- I know I'm not wearing any underwear.
Mark, I'm homeless.
(laughs)
Where is underwear?
Mark excavating for clothes.
And trashcans is not
necessarily a practical way
to live your life.
So underwear, it's not really a commodity.
- No, I know that, but,
but it's Oh boy, it happened.
It's like here, we're
going to help you it.
- Right, right.
You didn't want back up.
- Your junk is hanging out
Well figure it out.
- I was trying to seduce you Mark.
I'm being a little coy.
Here's the last one.
I was Kate.
Rebecca is she called
Rebecca Christian wig.
She be like, Oh my God,
- I liked blondes but not with beards.
- How dare you!
Buy me a razor daddy, what am I?
Caitlyn Jenner.
Bougie bitch.
I'm homeless.
- And then eventually came to LA ?
- Your standards
Yes and then I came to LA two years ago
and I went to the beach
and it was like Chloe gown.
And then I just feel like oh,
they've lived like that there.
It's perfect.
It's all kind of incumbents.
All these weirdos.
And that's when Bonnie
turned Nellie, she's a witch.
- Where's your brother?
- Probably like school somewhere.
Let's not discuss it just
because my family has a name.
I don't want to say the
name, but it's a name.
Leave it there.
It's unimportant.
I don't want to, I'm not
making an impression.
I'm not trying to be like, Oh no
- Your story..
I'll give you a little bit of your story.
- Let's just say where ,
I'm this?
My brother is my, my duo.
He's like suit and tie and yes, sir.
And go to work for the family.
And he's the, you know what I mean?
Like I used to be the
I was the gifted child
and then I became bad.
So he's become, he's like
the good little boy, like
imagine like I'm going go
work for daddy's company.
That's him.
I'm not going to do that shit.
500 million dollars just for the.
(scoffs)
The fuck are you going to do with that?
If all you do all day
sit at a fucking desk,
telling people what to do
get a blow job from his secretary.
No Mark.
I'm into men.
I'm gay.
I'm not going to pretend to be straight.
For anything
(laughs)
(inaudible)
Why am I still fun?
Anyway, I'm sorry.
I talked to much.
- You're fine.
- I can cut it at a class on top of it.
(giggle)
- Your fine.
I know I am, but what are you
girls want to have fun.